Cartographers used to include fake towns on
their maps to catch forgers.
Sudan is the only country that still has crucifixion
as an official form of capital punishment.
Famous left-handed people include Napoleon,
Da Vinci, Michelangelo, Einstein, Newton,
Bill Gates, Oprah, Obama and Jimi Hendrix.
Honeybees always know where the Sun is, even
if it's on the other side of the world.
You have a better chance of getting accepted
to Harvard University than getting a job at
an Apple Store.
For some reason South Korean soap operas are
popular in Cuba.
Crime, disease and average walking speed increase
by 15% as a city doubles in size.
Within 200 yards of the flat in Islington
where George Orwell had the idea for 1984,
there are now 32 CCTV cameras.
Every living thing can be anaesthetised, even
plants.
Despite their successful use since the mid-19th
century, no one really understands how anaesthetics
work.
India has a higher population than the entire
Western Hemisphere.
Elephants have the longest pregnancy in the
animal kingdom at 22 months.
The longest human pregnancy on record is 17
months, 11 days.
In the U.S., meat is treated with carbon monoxide
to make it look fresh.
India has a Bill of Rights for cows.
In 1980, a Las Vegas hospital suspended workers
for betting on when patients would die.